my kids love their toys
there's the ice cream where's the ice
cream and most of the time i love that
they love their toys especially when i'm
working from home but here's some bad
news toy departments across the country
may have some empty shelves this fall
and the toys that we will be able to buy
they're about to get more expensive in
some cases we're talking double digit
increases yeah you've heard a lot about
inflation which was already prompting
toy companies to raise their prices but
you may not have heard about a small
coronavirus outbreak a few months ago
over in china that might be pushing
those toy prices even higher
that one outbreak has caused ripple
effects across the entire 95 billion
dollar toy industry it feels way too
early to think about the holidays but
seriously should we all be stockpiling
toys now to fill those stockings as a
reporter for the wall street journal who
obviously has some skin in the game here
i decided to dig into the data to find
out what happened and how it's going to
affect all of us toy consumers
[Music]
here in the us three billion toys are
sold every single year and according to
the toy association approximately 85
percent of those toys are produced over
in china some in the industry even joke
that china is the new north pole and
while there are factories all over china
guangdong province in southern china is
considered the toy capital of the world
since ocean freight is much cheaper than
air most of those toys travel stateside
by boat not plane but just like an
entire highway gets jammed when one car
breaks down
shipping lanes get backed up when
something goes wrong at a port
and that's what happened back in may
when some dock workers and others at the
yantian port in guangdong province
tested positive for kovit 19. yantian is
not as well known as other major ports
but it's so big that it moved 50 more
cargo than the port of la last year
which is the busiest port in america
even though there were just over a dozen
coronavirus cases chinese authorities
came down hard and shut down parts of
the province operations at the port fell
to 30 capacity and hundreds of thousands
of containers piled up on the docks with
ships unable to pick them up as you can
see in the satellite image because goods
simply weren't moving some factories
even shut down it took nearly a month
for the port to resume full operations
but the impact is far from over the
backup has affected all kinds of
companies and another coronavirus
cluster up near shanghai is having a
similar effect on another huge port but
for toy companies the outbreak at
yantian has been particularly painful
that's because toys are shipped out of
china in the summer in order to hit us
shelves in time for the holidays with so
many businesses desperate to move
product shipping prices which were
already high soared to new records a
forty foot container that cost about
seven thousand dollars to ship in
mid-may rose to nine thousand dollars by
mid-june and prices continued to climb
from there with container space tight
some toy makers even engaged in bidding
wars just to move their product that
especially hurts small businesses which
don't have the big shipping contracts or
clout that say a walmart or a target
does
one business owner told me he just paid
more than 24 thousand dollars to get
product off the docks at yantian stuff
that was supposed to ship a month ago
even major toy makers which have the
ability to make products in different
countries and use various shipping lanes
have been talking about how crazy ocean
freight costs are in their earnings
calls experts i talk to don't expect the
shipping issues or costs to get ironed
out before the end of the year and that
means toy companies are probably gonna
have to pick and choose what gets
shipped
that ultimately means fewer toy options
for the holidays and higher prices for
the toys that do make it onto shelves
toy giants like hasbro and mattel were
already planning price hikes due to the
rising cost of raw material and labor
and analysts i talked to say that these
shipping backlogs are likely to push
those hikes even higher and what about
smaller companies some say they simply
won't be able to survive if they don't
increase their prices and unfortunately
analysts say that once toy prices go up
it's very unlikely they'll ever come
back down so if toy prices are going up
should we all go stockpile toys right
now well not if you want that shiny new
stuff that'll be on shelves this fall
but the question is will we all be
willing to pay more for toys
based on recent trends it looks like the
answer to that question is yes toy sales
are better than ever and they're
expected to remain strong through the
end of the year
but you're the one buying toys so you
tell me let me know by leaving a comment
below
and if you want to know more about the
news events that are impacting our world
subscribe to the channel for more videos
like this one
see you next time
[Music]